Russia has urged the last Defenders of
the Ukrainian Port City of Maria Paul to
lay down their arms they gave a deadline
of early Sunday morning
small groups of Fighters have been
holding out in a steel plant in the city
elsewhere Russia launched missiles in
the capital Kiev and stepped up shelling
attacks against the city of kharkif
it's the latest strike to hit the city
in a deadly week
with many civilians among the dead and
injured
this time at least two people were
killed with over a dozen more wounded
Ukrainian officials fear the bombardment
is just a Prelude to a new assault on
the strategically important city
just 40 kilometers from the Russian
border
far to the southeast Russian forces
gather for a new offensive on another
key Target
mariupo
the port city has been besieged for
weeks
now Moscow says its Defenders have been
forced back to hear the giant ads of
style Industrial District
the entire urban area of maripole has
been completely cleared of the militants
of the Nazi formation as of foreign
Ministries and Ukrainian troops the
remnants of the Ukrainian group are
blocked in the territory of the azov
star metallurgical plant their only
chance to save their lives is to
voluntarily lay down their arms and
surrender
Ukrainian president zielinski warned
that Russia risks jeopardizing further
peace talks
the elimination of our troops of our men
in Marriott pool
will put an end to any negotiations
you post last Defenders cut off
and Russian forces posed to strike
ukrainians feared the city May well soon
finally fall
did have your correspondent Rebecca
Ritter's is in Kiev with us now Rebecca
bring us up with the latest the
surrender window for Ukrainian troops
and Maria pole is open it's closing fast
what is the latest you've been able to
gather from there
well William
days ago Russia reported that they took
they managed to take the actual Port of
that City where that was being guarded
by the so-called 36 Battalion more than
a thousand soldiers Ukrainian soldiers
from that Battalion were reported to
have been taken and others managed to
get into the as of Steel uh Factory
which is where the other Battalion are
have managed to be holding out that's
where the the last Ukrainian stronghold
in that City Now lies and overnight
around 3 A.M local time Russia ordered a
cease and desist a surrender and die
order if you will uh saying that they
will uh very close to capturing and they
will kill those soldiers as well that
City obviously a key Target of Vladimir
Putin in this war he wants to have
something to be able to report back some
good news if you will for the Russian
side and a taking of marry uphol would
be that victory that he's looking for by
uh by all accounts uh certainly ahead of
the main night Victory Day in Russia
and you've just mentioned it we heard it
in the report and zelenski warning that
the peace talks with Russia will end if
Russian forces execute Ukrainian troops
in that capture of Maria Paul what's
been the reaction to that
he did say that in response to that
surrender and die order in a statement
overnight but in all honesty the peace
talks have been stalled for days in fact
weeks now ever since Russian troops were
treated from those Northern regions
regions around Kiev and the atrocities
came to light of what happened like what
happened there under Russian control so
the peace talks pretty much dead in the
water in the last few weeks anyway
although we are getting reports that
Roman Abramovich the Russian oligarch is
actually in Kiev this weekend he's here
trying to revive those talks but little
information has come at us to whether he
will be successful and of course as
zelinsky was saying if those troops in
mariu poll are killed by the Russians
then the peace talks are really dead
and trying to help us understand because
Russia says it's moving its its focus to
the East and yet attacks have
intensified across the country including
in the capital Kiev where you are so
what exactly is the situation in Kiev
um right now
well Ukrainian authorities are preparing
for renewed attacks on Ukraine they're
seen as retaliatory attacks for other
attacks that ukrainians have made on to
the Russian sides namely the warship
that was sunk in the Black Sea
um you know I would say that the city is
trying to find some kind of normality in
this terrible situation that people find
themselves in people are out in the
streets I mean maybe not right now the
weather's not that great this morning it
is Sunday morning so people at home but
we have in the recent days been seeing a
lot of people out on the streets trying
to kind of
get on with their lives as best they can
some restaurants are starting to open
we're seeing non-essential shops opening
as well after you know really weeks of
of nothing in the city people living
indoors people living underground and
people now really just trying to make
the most of this sort of relative calm
although having said that where there
were a couple of successful attacks by
Russia over the weekend two Munitions
factories were hit both uh yesterday and
the day before so um Sirens Are Ringing
throughout the night and also through
the day so it's definitely a Target and
all authorities are remaining people to
warning people to remain Vigilant here
Rebecca Raiders in Kiev thanks very much